- I could hear y'all coming
before y'all even got out here.
(Sheryl laughing)
No, no.
And so I'm curious cause like,
I know in our, in my glam-
we call it the glam room.
Glow, my makeup artist,
she's the one who picks the music.
We always have a, we
always have music going.
- [Quinta] Yes.
- in the glam room.
So do y'all have that going on?
And who gets to pick it?
- [Lisa] Okay, let me just say,
(Kelly laughing)
- [Quinta] Oh, Lord.
- Let me just say that for one solid month
we heard Beyonce's entire album
- My Fault.
- and we enjoyed it.
- It was great.
(Kelly applauds)
Fantastic.
- It only takes a million
dollars to look like this.
- Oh my God.
(Kelly laughing)
A billion, Sheryl?
- A billion.
- But anytime I walk into
a hair and makeup trailer
where it's just Miss Shirley Ralph.
I'm sorry, The Honorable, Shirley Ralph.
- [Sheryl] Yes.
- I hear music that I grew up with.
I'm hearing the old, I'm hearing Chaka.
I'm hearing EWF, I'm
hearing the Commodores,
- Yeah.
Marvin Gaye.
I'm hearing the stuff
that I like to sing along
to and I love it.
And we get in there and
we're both jammin', right?
But then the second she's not there,
they put on something
like progressive jazz.
I had to say the other
day when I was there,
I'm like, "What?"
I tolerated it for a minute
because it is the hair
and makeup's, that's their room.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- I'm not trying to tell
anybody what to play
but I'm telling you, my hair
God dusted had something
on where I was like, just find a melody.
(Sheryl laughing)
Just find a beat.
- Where is it?
- Anything, I'll listen to country,
I'll listen to classical,
I'll listen to pop rock,
I'll listen to anything
but progressive jazz.
- [Quinta] I think that was techno.
- Oh and the-
- That's techno.
Honey, I know the difference
between techno and progressive jazz.
This was like--
- Are you sure?
- In the morning too.
- [Kelly] I'm like, what
is progressive jazz?
(Group making jazz sounds)
'Cause I like jazz.
I'm just like, what makes that like-
- [Sheryl] Thelonious Monk, maybe?
- Yes.
Like Mingus.
- Don't play me Mingus at 8:00 AM.
- Then listen, jazz is
our last real art form.
Don't knock jazz.
(Quinta laughing)
- [Lisa] I'm not mocking it.
I'm not not mocking it.
- [Kelly] She's knocking progressive.
- [Lisa] I am not mocking it.
And by the way, if you
play old school standards.
If you play, look, have Ella sing.
- [Kelly] Like, I like Ella.
I grew up on like, that
kind of stuff I love.
- [Lisa] Okay, that's fine.
- That's why I was like,
"What's progressive?"
It feels like very Will Ferrell,
like Ron Burgundy, like-
(Sheryl laughing)
- [Lisa] Yes!
That's it.
- [Kelly] It just feels-
It feels like
I'm gonna play the sexy jazz flute.
Like, you know, it's something,
it feels interesting.
- [Lisa] But at least
there was like a rhythm
you could hang your hat on in that song.
- It takes a different brain to understand
that kind music.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Lisa] Okay.
- [Sheryl] And we need all brains.
I'm a Philistine.
- I will say-
"We need all brains", is crazy, Sheryl.
(Kelly and Quinta laughing)
- [Sheryl] We do.
- [Lisa] How come when
you're in the trailer...
- [Sheryl] Thank you.
- [Kelly] Yeah, but she's not
listening to progressive jazz,
she's listening to Marvin Gaye.
- [Lisa] That's what she said.
That's what I'm saying.
You're not trying to find it.
- My husband loves jazz.
The senator.
We will listen to jazz all day long.
- That's what Tyler does.
Tyler does this face.
- He does Q.
- He does that face.
- Gotta love jazz.
I agree with Lisa that
at 04:30 in the morning
when I'm just trying to-
- Tyler does this.
Tyler goes-
- [Kelly] I don't like-
I will say though,
I don't like anything for a month.
A month.
Like that's a lot of something.
'cause y'all said you played
something for like a month.
- Beyonce.
- I love Beyonce.
That's my Texas Queen.
I love Beyonce.
- I'm just saying it came out and-
- Anything for a month.
- I couldn't put anything else on.
And in the morning when you wake up
and you wanna feel good
about yourself and you wanna,
so it fit the vibe for
04:30 in the morning.
- I like that.
You're go-to for-
- [Sheryl] That's true.
- Yeah, okay.
I get that.
Okay.
- Cost a billion dollars.
(Lisa and Quinta laughing)